oh boy there's been many I got my family
standing over there probably the worst
okay I'm a child of behaving so multiple
fashions don'ts I guess late 70s maybe I
don't know early punk days yeah the hair
the hair under their armpits shaved
heads big makeup no bra it was nasty it
was nasty lots of colors let's make up
no hair on the head
lots under the arms it was bad I guess
the worst ones would be the acid wash
jeans that are tapered so remember this
awful look with the LA gears with the
multiple shoelaces
and I think I wore a pink hue hopefully
shirt with it so that's probably the
worst fashion mistake popped collar on
the Polo all eighth grade that would
probably be my worst fashion mistake all
the school pictures the collar was
popped and the bright color polo shirt I
don't have any you see me and it was
straight milk it was my cringe phase but
I still am kind of proud of the cringe
phase I was totally like the hot topic
emo gal and I wore like the tutus and
the fuzz in my hair and it's pretty
cringy but like I'm still kind of when I
see the old photos I'm still like yeah
getting up in the morning getting
dressed I had the worst fashion sense in
the world I just wear whatever whatever
comes out into her first goozle Oh
before I got married I used to wear
socks with my foot plus my wife broke me
into have it yeah wearing jeans jeans do
not do not look good on the hoodie I was
going through this whole emo stage in
middle school so I thought it was really
cool with my green ugly shirt that said
converse on it and I had a orange bright
orange seashell and I just wore my hair
in my face a worse fashion mistake was
when I was 8 and I had a bright rainbow
colored like ridiculous like spotty like
shorts and wore them everywhere I were a
lot of like swishy pants like the swishy
suits with turtlenecks all the time and
I also were a lot of big bows so like
black girl the clothes you know
like a lot of things all over my hair
all mismatched so that's nice to do in
high school I had this thing that I
would do where I would be like bummy
cute so my hair would be done and I
would have on a little bit of lip gloss
from Victoria's Secret but then I would
wear like a baggy white tee with
sweatpants and Jordans and I don't know
why I ever did that I thought that was
okay baggy cargos baggy cargos really
really a snapback that's worn really
just wrongly like I would wear it like
I'm the tip of my head cuz I thought it
looked freaking cool long socks and like
some knockoff Congress I probably say
like some Sun like Reebok basketball
shirt some Reebok basketball shorts with
just like Nike like I used to wear just
like nike socks with like any type of
shoe and it was just so bad I liked
Reebok shorts awesome Nike shoes are
nike socks with like some like New
Balance shoes I think I put a purple
jacket with you know like the Mishnah
and and orange Peruvian heads because it
was very cold I think that's the worst I
think I did I I don't because I'm a
fashion designer it was after a party
the next day
I wa I had help with my train I like
good tops and
my good hair but training I growth too
fast and so everybody should I wear I wa
can see my hundred pan and I put some
fruit like that every day was a fashion
mistake bright hot pink like football
jersey with sparkles is like covered in
sparkles and camo cargo shorts well I am
color deficient kind of colorblind so
there's been a couple of times where I'm
just completely off my girlfriend else
we know each other get the right thing
he's a match together so yeah I was the
first day of sixth grade I wore a blue
poncho a jean skirt that you couldn't
see beneath the poncho and gym shoes and
glasses and a ponytail so all together
or not not a good look
okay well I was in fifth grade and it
was picture day and I wore this purple
shirt and it I thought it looked so cool
and it had this sequined skirt and it
was seriously it was so reflective and
all the sequins by the time day was over
they were just all over the school
and he was really embarrassing but
probably everything up to this point
a Kinzua bridge State Park t-shirt mix
with Levi's you had that ready no I just
thought about what I'm wearing oh my
goodness probably when I was in Middle
School I would wear the exact same shirt
every single day and had this one put on
it and had like those long sleeves which
just doesn't really work well and it
just say have a picture of a little
small cool cooler and it's a I'm a
little cooler on it and I was my worst
fashion mistake okay I used to wear like
overalls that had like these patches on
them and I thought they were so sweet
because it had like a smiley face patch
and a little rainbow and then I just
looked back like why did I wear those
right now
[Music]
and I always in second grade I was
chewing on my hair so my mom cut it to
about here so I had this like a tiny cut
around my head I was pretty bad
alright so it has been it was a middle
school and I don't know what my moment
let me go like that but it was red pants
with red shoes in a red shirt and I had
a red head now it's not just like
fashionable red no it was like a
burgundy red it was like a bright red
and then it was like with like red and
then this one cool kind of like a purple
red it was not pretty I thought it
matched at that moment but I saw a
picture it wasn't pretty
because I really believe in fashion
I mean by definition for you to have a
fashion mistake you'd have to care about
fashion that's pretty much like my
answers haha taste the suit
there is no fashion
[Music]